[Musik]
versprochen hatten sie einen neuen Stil
mehr miteinander mehr Respekt Olaf
Scholz hat eine Politik des Brechens von
Vereinbarung bis nachtretend und des
nach Verhandelns den Segen gegeben die
Ampel wollte gönnen können Brücken bauen
und jetzt sind wir ein Jahr später in
einem totalen Durcheinander in der
Regierung und ich erwarte dass alle sich
da am Riemen reißen
Fortschritt das war das Ziel vor einem
Jahr frostig ist die Stimmung jetzt ich
finde extrem schwierig gerade zu
ertragen dass das Kanz stammt sich
überall Fachmeinungen hinwegzusetzen
scheint und das ist etwas was mir nicht
ganz in den Kopf fällt
drei Atomkraftwerke sollen bis April
weiterlaufen für diese Entscheidung
bemüht Olaf Scholz der vorher viel von
neuem Stil und Augenhöhe gesprochen
hatte ein Machtinstrument
§ 1 der Geschäftsordnung seine
Richtlinienkompetenz es wird jetzt nicht
mehr geprüft ob das wohl noch notwendig
ist und es wird dann tatsächlich
entschieden es wird jetzt produziert ein
Kanzler der die
Richtlinienkompetenz zieht der weiß dass
die Koalition in einer schweren Krise
ist für einige grüne wie Jürgen Trittin
bricht mit der Entscheidung eine Welt
zusammen andere zeigen sich erleichtert
die FDP wollte eigentlich viel mehr
verkauft das Ergebnis trotzdem als ihren
Sieg für viele in der Fraktion aber ist
das letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen
jetzt laufen sie erstmal bis April das
ist schon mal ein erster Schritt aber es
kommen ja weitere Winter und deshalb
muss man natürlich auch über eine
Verlängerung dann diskutieren der Graben
zwischen grün und gelb dürfte sich bald
noch weiter vertiefen wenn es um die
sogenannten sektorziele für den
Klimaschutz geht es droht derselbe
Streit nur heftiger
und auch das Geld liefert weiter
wachsendes bruchpotenzial Thema
Schuldenbremse Christian Lindner will
die 2023 unbedingt wieder einhalten und
baut gerade einen Schuldenberg um sie
herum der Bundesrechnungshof nennt das
in dieser Woche verfassungs- und
haushaltsrechtlich problematisch der
Koalitionspartner SPD fühlt sich
bestätigt
und natürlich müssen wir mit Blick auf
die Zukunft gucken dass der Haushalt
vernünftig aufgestellt ist und ich
glaube dass die Aussetzung der
Schuldenbremse 23 notwendig sein wird
und das wird auch auf uns zukommen da
bin ich ziemlich sicher auch
problematisch für lindner selbst die
Union in der Opposition eigentlich
größte Anhängerin der Schuldenbremse
könnte sich jetzt vorstellen die wieder
auszusetzen man müsse sich ehrlich
machen alles ausschöpfen und wenn danach
noch der Bedarf verbleiben sollte für
zusätzliche krediteaufnahmen und wir
dann auch noch in einer Notlage sind
dann kann man auch mit uns konstruktiv
über das einmalige Aussetzen der
Schuldenbremse sprechen aber wir wollen
den ehrlichen Umgang mit der
Schuldenbremse
einig sind sich große Teile der Ampel
immerhin bei einem Thema einig im Ärger
über den Kanzler china will sich in den
Hamburger Hafen Einkaufen sechs
Ministerien sprechen sich dringend
dagegen aus Olaf Scholz will es trotzdem
weiter prüfen es folgt ein Ampel
Aufschrei auf Twitter und vor Kameras
wir haben einmal gesehen wie es ist
abhängig zu sein von einem Land wie
Russland wir sollten diesen Fehler nicht
noch einmal machen es gibt die Bedenken
und Einsprüche der der sechs Ministerien
es gibt auch unsere Bedenken aus der
Ampelkoalition und von Opposition
sowieso und natürlich ist es das was
oben drüber steht immer kritische
Infrastruktur gehört in öffentliche Hand
und deswegen nicht das Olaf Scholz das
Kanzleramt sich da erklärt nicht
ausschweigt das ist auch nicht
zielführend gerade in dieser Zeit in
dieser Debatte wenn es um Souveränität
in unserem Land geht der Streit um die
Atomkraftwerke das Gezerre bei der
Schuldenbremse das china-problem des
Kanzlers eines hat diese Woche deutlich
gezeigt das Wohlwollen in der Ampel ist
aufgebraucht im Zweifel geht es jetzt
gegeneinander